good morning Hank it's Friday June 22nd
you'll never guess where I am unless you
guess an airport in which case you'd
guess right I'm always in airports Hank
the day before yesterday I moved to
Indianapolis Indiana and today I'm
moving to Washington DC fortunately this
move is only for five days I'm going to
the American Library Association annual
conference which is like the librarian
conference for the entire year it's huge
don't worry I will be reporting back on
Tuesday a lot of things are happening is
this librarian conference I'm going to
be accepting the prince honor for an
abundance of katherines and I'm also
going to be on a panel with Judy Blume
Judy Blume Judy Blume and I are going to
be speaking together from the same table
but before I can do any of that I have
to get a haircut and I can't get a
haircut in Indianapolis because I'm
already in the airport and they don't
have any scissors so I'm gonna have to
get one in Washington DC I hope they
have good you know haircutting places
there I'm a little bit worried that
wherever I go they're going to make me
look like a senator Hank as you will no
doubt recall I had the senator look when
I was about 12 years old and it didn't
really work for me well Hank I have now
gotten my hair cut do you like it you
like it I like it I'm pretty happy with
it I went to a barbershop in Washington
DC called Louise and the guy who cut my
hair had cut the hair of both Bill
Clinton and Willie Nelson and when he
told me this information I was like hmm
Bill Clinton Willie Nelson are both
historical figures whose work I admire
but I'm not necessarily looking to
emulate their hairstyles Hank I've
always felt that hair is a fair
indicator of one's political position
you know you can always tell right-wing
Republicans because they have the
Senator haircut and you can always tell
like big-time
lefty hippies because they've got the
long hair so I explained to the guy in
Louie's that I wanted to cut that was
somewhere between the Willie Nelson on
the far left and the Bill Clinton in the
center because I'm a liberal but I'm not
you know like a pot-smoking tax-evading
liberal all things considered I think
you did a pretty good job of giving me a
haircut that's you know good hair
for a liberal young guy but not a real
liberal young guy hey thanks for all
your good wishes this week as we've
traveled across the country I'll see you
on Monday